president Trump officially kicking off
his 2020 reelection campaign last night
in Florida igniting the crowd with a
wild 75 minutes speech as you double
down on campaign promises took aim at
the Democrats and promised to quote
bring an earthquake to the ballot box
our economy is the envy of the world
remember the statement from the previous
administration you need a magic wand to
bring back manufacture well will tell
sleepy Joe that we found the magic wand
we accomplished more than any other
president has in the first two and a
half years of a presidency and under
circumstances that no president has had
to deal with before if I got a subpoena
for emails if I deleted one email like a
love note to Melania it's the electric
chair for Trump the Democrat Party has
become more radical more dangerous and
more unhinged than at any point in the
modern history of our country they want
to destroy you and they want to destroy
our country as we know it a vote for any
Democrat in 2020 is a vote for the rise
of radical socialism and the destruction
of the American Dream America will never
be a socialist country and remember the
only thing these corrupt politicians
will understand is an earthquake at the
ballot box and then a predictable move
democratic 2020 contenders were quick to
criticize the president's speech
listening to Trump made me feel very
much that he is a man living in a
parallel universe
a man way out of touch with the needs of
ordinary people and a man who must be
defeated this president wants us to keep
looking in the rearview mirror instead
of looking out of the front windshield
this is a president who wants to make
America great again instead of making
America a great today
he does not
that we need a leader of our united
states who is focused on the challenges
of the 21st century Joe Budden also
going after the president tweeting the
Trump quote continues to undermine our
standing in the world and our core
values are under attack here at home and
abroad button also taking credit for
terms booming economy saying he
inherited it from the obama-biden
administration all right Deena before we
talk about your reaction to the speech
we should note that the president raised
almost 25 million dollars over a 24-hour
period
I mean Biden the Democrat raised the
most over that 24 hour period was 6
million so he basically almost that is a
great comparison because President Trump
is pulling from the entire Republican
universe and the Democrats are spread
around 25 feet row but that's even if
you combine the top 25 million dollars
in one day is absolutely incredible and
not only that but they are collecting
more information than they've ever had
before so that they can reach out to
them again will you walk precincts for
us will you sign people up to vote will
you make sure that your neighbor gets to
the polling booth because I think the
last night was incredible but that's not
necessarily what were you want me to
talk about I would say that my initial
reaction is he's in great position as
most incumbent presidents are when they
go to run for re-election they are in
great shape he's probably even in even
better shape then Obama was and
certainly that in President Bush was I
think the war was a different scenario
and not comparable I think this again
comes down to about four states yeah and
in those four states Florida being
probably the most important a Republican
has to win Florida and that's why he was
there last night and they had a really
good good start yeah that was a great
start and Greg one of the central themes
of last night was it wasn't really about
Trump it was about the people that put
him there and he's responsible for a
movement and he's taking care of those
people and let's just react to how he
pulled his own audience to see what his
re-election slogan should be watch this
so I'm gonna ask you to vote on it I'm
gonna go make America great again
then Keep America great
let me just hear about your cheers what
you like make America great again Keep
America great Wow
I'm sorry magic country but that wasn't
too close was a good moment last night
you know the Democrats have a big
challenge here because there's so many
of them and he just he just makes them
seem so small by his outsized
personality it's pointless to credit for
me to criticize him because I was wrong
on the initial go around so if I picked
the wrong stock before don't come to me
for investment advice so at the because
I would have liked more unscripted
riffing because that helps me with my
show like I could build my entire a
block but that'll come I'm more
interested in the media response to this
you know once CNN was criticized they
turned it off I mean you're the your
news network you're not allowed to turn
it off we can change the channel we can
turn it off but you're a cable news
network meanwhile you have a lot of
emotional responses from you know
Morning Joe and you know calling them
fat Elvis and they're all trying to read
Trump's mind yet and the thing is
they're trying they react emotionally to
this because the deeds favored Trump if
you look at the economy the military
trade jobs and prison reform all that's
left that you can go after his
personality and micro flaws and tweets
but the unspoken truth when you go
through the achievements that that's I
wish the media would understand is that
Trump is a centrist I went through the
ice at Ian's went through the list
strong military center-right prison
reform center-left
cut taxes sent to right trade wars
Center left a rejection of military
actions libertarian Pro free speech
libertarian don't burn the flag
center-right conclusion he's right down
the middle and that confounds the media
because they don't know how to handle
that he's exactly what America wants
yeah Greg brought up the media and won
for a president an incumbent to launch
his re-election campaign in front of
20,000 people in primetime
the media did not treat it the way it
would treat a normal president in these
times it was it was obviously blacked
out on CNN after the first couple
minutes MSNBC dumped out of it they
didn't cover it seriously and everybody
was just responding with snark and they
weren't even discussing you know how he
was framing issues kind of the
rhetorical flourishes he was using how
he was going to you know map out
different items that he was gonna play
to in the in the campaign they don't
discuss it seriously it's all sarcastic
well I mean we could use a hype man but
you got a job offer here but it seems to
me that you know my experience of it was
so disappointing it was boring and I had
heard from all of you that you know the
Trump's big advantage is he's such a
great entertainer that he's so different
now you say they didn't treat him the
media like other presidential you know
incumbents right but he's not he's
different
Trump is different than anybody else
he's had 60 rallies of this kind in the
two-and-a-half years he's been in the
White House so I guess people are saying
like hey this is like a rerun it's like
a summer rerun I've seen this act before
and there was very little knew in terms
of agenda I didn't see anything new in
fact so he's done all this before and
the audience's say is shouting lock her
up about Hillary Clinton but it wasn't
she the can--it in 2016 Jessie I don't
get it so they say locker up CNN sucks a
bill the wall you talk about all the
achievements I think his number-one
promise had been to build but whoa well
now there here we are again it's Bill
the world so there's no agenda failure
to deliver on the wall on repeal and
replace the Obamacare
the middle class tax cut if you're rich
we can argue about how much the middle
class benefited Jesse and Greg and I
have argued about this but there's no
question the rich definitely benefited I
consider myself rich and I definitely
got hit but you need to get richer
brother because if you're Wall Street
you benefited but I'm just saying if you
talk about student debt if you talk
about the you know affordable housing in
this country if you talk about
international chaos and
Ron Iraq China in terms of the tariffs
you'd have to say hey what did he say
about the news well I think we could
argue about the agenda but Emily you
know I think it was Barack Obama who
talked about george w bush for eight
years and now the media is complaining
that Trump hit Hillary a few times I
mean that's what Pelican motto yeah you
had to clean it up totally and I do
think that there's a difference in
perspective of that I think the
president did a great job of actually
having that continuity so he said look
this is what we've accomplished in the
last couple years and here are the
continued themes that I've been working
on here are what we can look forward to
and I think frankly it doesn't matter
what he said because it was the success
from the get-go because of the thousands
of RSVPs because people lined up for 40
hours to get inside that arena and
because the TV cameras showed a packed
house juxtaposed that and what happened
last night with the two days of
democratic debates that are gonna happen
next week in Miami and we saw a taste of
it by the candidates the Democratic
candidates responses with Bernie saying
it was absolute nonsense what he said
really told that to the people who stood
in line for 40 hours they beg to differ
and so will the voters Jessie
Republicans fun Democrats funeral oh you
know what I fear it is I think they're
though the money he raised was something
to see yeah and I think that the
incumbent definitely has an advantage
but I will say I just I don't understand
what's the celebrate it just looked like
a rehash well success we play it that's
right networks don't carry him at all so
it would have been nice for them to show
the audience anyway